WHILE RUSSIA IS SAID TO BE
MOVING ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
OUT OF KHERSON, UKRAINIAN
DEFENSE OFFICIALS SAY THEY'RE
BRINGING MORE TROOPS IN TO
DEFEND THE OCCUPIED CENTER
AGAINST A NEW COUNTER-OFFENSIVE
BY UKRAINE'S MILITARY.
SO LET'S BRING IN CNN'S CLARISSA
WARD IN MYKOLAIV, UKRAINE.
AT THE SITE OF AN OVERNIGHT
STRIKE THAT LEFT SEVERAL
INJURED.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
THERE.
>> Reporter: SO THIS SOUTHERN
PORT CITY IS JUST 35 MILES AWAY
FROM KHERSON, BRIANNA, AND IT IS
GETTING SMACKED ALL THE TIME
THIS.
ATTACK TOOK PLACE IN THE EARLY
HOURS YESTERDAY MORNING.
TWO MISSILES, ONE LANDING RIGHT
BEHIND ME, YOU CAN SEE HERE, THE
SIDE OF THAT CRATER, AND THEN
THE SECOND LITERALLY SLAMMING
RIGHT INTO THAT APARTMENT
BUILDING, AND THE TOP COUPLE OF
FLOORS.
IT'S SOMETHING OF A MIRACLE,
BRIANNA, THAT NOBODY WAS KILLED
IN THIS.
AND WHAT IS SORT OF STRIKING IS
NOBODY HERE CAN SEEM TO WORK OUT
WHAT THE TARGET WAS.
THIS IS A RESIDENTIAL AREA.
THERE ARE APARTMENT BUILDINGS
ALL AROUND.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU OVER THERE,
THIS IS THE CHILDREN'S
PLAYGROUND.
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S LEFT OF
IT.
NOW, THE STRIKE HAPPENED IN THE
EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING, AS I
MENTIONED, SO NO CHILDREN WERE
OUT PLAYING.
BUT I THINK IT GIVES YOU A FEEL
FOR JUST HOW CHALLENGING IT IS
FOR SO MANY UKRAINIANS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE SORT OF
EMBATTLED SOUTHERN REGION TO GO
BACK, HAVING ANY SEMBLANCE OF A
NORMAL LIFE, IT IS ALSO VERY
STRIKING, YOU CAN SEE BEHIND ME,
THEY ARE ALREADY CLEANING UP,
THEY ARE WELDING THOSE PIPES.
THOSE WATER PIPES, BACK
TOGETHER.
THEY ARE CLEARING DEBRIS.
THEY ARE COMING AND GRABBING
WHATEVER PERSONAL POSSESSIONS
THEY CAN SALVAGE TO GET OUT OF
HERE.
WHICH AGAIN, I THINK IT SPEAKS
TO THE SORT OF BROADER
RESILIENCE OF THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, AND CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE
OF MYKOLAIV.
BUT DEFINITELY THEY HAVE NOT HAD
A BREAK BETWEEN S-300 MISSILE
STRIKE, CONSTANT DRONE STRIKES,
AND THIS PLACE IS REALLY BEARING
THE BRUNT.
ELECTRICITY IS OUT ALL THE TIME.
WATER, YOU CAN'T GET FRESH WATER
HERE NOW.
THEY HAVE SORT OF SALT WATER AND
THEN THEY HAVE DAILY LINES
ACROSS TOWN WHERE YOU CAN GO AND
GET FRESH WATER.
BUT IT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION HERE INDEED.
>> JUST THAT SCENE OF THAT
RAINBOW-COLORED METAL, SO
CLEARLY A CHILD'S PLAYGROUND BY
YOU THERE, IT JUST STOPS YOU IN
YOUR TRACKS AS YOU'RE WATCHING.
YOU CAN HELP US MAKE SENSE WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN KHERSON?
SO OBVIOUSLY VERY DIFFERENT
STORIES COMING FROM RUSSIA, AND
UKRAINE IS ACTUALLY SAYING
THEY'RE BRINGING IN MORE TROOPS.
>> Reporter: SO THIS IS SORT OF
A VERY DIFFICULT ONE TO HAVE A
GOOD READ ON, BECAUSE IT'S A
RUSSIAN-CONTROLLED AREA, BECAUSE
THE ONLY INFORMATION WE GET OUT
OF THERE OFFICIALLY IS RUSSIAN
STATE PROPAGANDA.
THEY SAY THEY'VE BEEN EVACUATING
CIVILIANS, THAT THEY'RE DOING IT
BECAUSE THE UKRAINIANS ARE
PREPARING AN IMMINENT ATTACK,
THE UKRAINIANS SAY THAT IS
NONSENSE.
WE ACTUALLY MANAGED TO SPEAK TO
SOMEONE ON THE GROUND IN THE
CITY OF KHERSON.
HE SAID THAT RUSSIA HAS PULLED
OUT ITS CIVILIAN ADMINISTRATIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE, THE PASSPORT
OFFICE, THE PENSION FUND, THE
FIREFIGHTERS, THEY HAVE ALL BEEN
CALLED OUT OF THE CITY.
ALONG WITH A LOT OF THE SOLDIERS
WHO HAD BEEN THERE FOR THE
BETTER PART OF THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS.
BUT THEY ARE REPLACING SOME OF
THAT, THOSE SOLDIERS, WITH
NEWER, YOUNGER SOLDIERS, WHO
THIS RESIDENT WE SPOKE TO
BELIEVED TO BE CONSCRIPTS, THAT
ACTUALLY TODAY, UKRAINIAN'S HEAD
OF INTELLIGENCE, OF DEFENSE
INTELLIGENCE, CAME OUT AND SAID,
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE
THE RUSSIANS ARE PREPARING TO
WITHDRAW.
DESPITE THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
HOPES THAT THAT MIGHT BE THE
CASE.
BUT IT LOOKS INSTEAD THAT THEY
ARE PREPARING FOR SOME KIND OF A
MISSION TO TRY TO DEFEND THE
CITY, AND TO CONTINUE TO HOLD ON
TO IT, AND THAT OF COURSE SPELLS
MISERY FOR MANY OF THE RESIDENTS
WHO ARE STILL HOLDING ON AND
HOLDING OUT IN KHERSON, WITH THE
HOPES THAT UKRAINE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO LIBERATE THE CITY SOON.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLEASE STAY SAFE.
AS YOU CONTINUE TO REPORT THERE
NEAR MYKOLAIV, WE APPRECIATE IT.